moi
[Applaudissements]
les conditions humanitaires
les conditions d'hygiène sont absolument
abominable puisque ce qui avait été
prévu pour 3000 personnes ne fonctionne
pas pour 20000 donc pas dessus c'est
l'horreur il ya aucun doute convives
comme des animaux un orient ils veulent
partir ils veulent partir et trouver
quelque chose de mieux
c'est ce que nous voulons ce alors nous
nous battons pour eux et pour nous ce
que demandent ces manifestants et
grévistes drapeaux grecs à bout de bras
que les demandeurs d'asile soit prise en
charge en grèce continentale pour être
renvoyé le plus vite possible
hors du pays nous exigeons qu aucun
nouveau cas ne soient construits sur les
îles la destruction immédiate des camps
existants à la fermeture du camp de
moria la sauvegarde des frontières et la
régulation des ong
nos vies ont été détruites pour
l'instant à lesbos il ya un peu plus de
80000 habitants et il ya plus de vingt
mille réfugiés
bon je vais lire c'est une proportion
qu'on trouve pas souvent en europe et ça
augmente de plus en plus vite puisque
maintenant c'est le passage le plus
simple c'est encore celui
qui vient de la turquie donc on dit les
îles grecques mais en fait ces trois
îles du gros sur nos dos qui sont
concernés selon l' agence des nations
unies pour les réfugiés
avec près de 60000 arrivé en 2019 soit
le double de l'année précédente
les îles grecques sont le principal
point d'entrée de l'immigration
clandestine dans l'union européenne
en fait que les violences actuelles
c'est c'est la pointe émergée
c'est l'explosion de quelque chose
qu'ils couvaient depuis déjà plusieurs
années et en fait ça traduit j'irai le
désespoir général et des réfugiés qui
sont là-bas et des habitants le
gouvernement devrait aller se noyer ce
n'est pas une situation acceptable
nos ils sont comme une zone de guerre je
ne dis pas que les immigrés clandestins
ne sont pas des êtres humains
ce sont des êtres humains mais nous ne
voulons pas de prison ferme et à
l'originalité c'est que la fureur s'est
pas tourné contre les réfugiés mais
contre la police et en particulier
contre le ch est que le gouvernement qui
se doutait bien que la population ne
voulait pas de ces travaux a envoyé en
supplément des crs et là vraiment ils
ont trouvé que
là c'en était trop quoi le gouvernement
a réussi à unir tous les habitants de
lesbos contre sa politique qui allait
créer un grand entrepôt de prisonniers
réfugiés et migrants
il se sent totalement isolés abandonnés
avec l'impression qu'on se dit que
pendant que les gens sont coincés en
grèce on les voit pas en europe on est
content il ya un peu de ça donc on leur
donne un peu d'argent pour les nourrir
comme ça ça évite quelques problèmes un
peu trop visible et puis voilà et puis
l'idée de les renvoyer dans le pays je
veux dire on peut pas les renvoyer
l'afghanistan n'a aucune envie de
reprendre tous ces gens la deuxième
nationalité c'est la series quand même
une guerre faisable et les renvoyer du
pays par lequel ils viennent c'est à
dire la turquie la turquie ne veut pas
les reprendre
[Musique]